idée qui en valent la peine
c'est bien de le noter
cher quand même hein on est d'accord
du stretching devant un tétraplégique
enfin bref j'essaye d'être écolo quand
être très difficile d'être exotique
donc
oui
voilà par exemple alors sa tête vous
donc oui l'exposition du cousin moi
bonsoir si pour vous allez bien
voilà vous ne voyez pas vous avez beau
c'est à dire que ça fait du bien mais
je voyage je voyage beaucoup avec
bon bah c'est là que j'ai su que
c'est nous adorent en vrai la suisse est
l'humour et je me déplacer beaucoup en
j'adore les expos injaz déjà dans les
surprendre mais moi plusieurs fois par
j'allais pas offert mes vannes sur les
faut éviter ça
aspirateurs
vous voyez j'ai pas beaucoup n'ont
vélo sauf que l'été dernier j'ai eu un
à moins qu'elles sont aspirante
semaine je prends des douches
évidemment fribourg je vous taquine je
musées par exemple je trouve ça
oulala oulala ça dort là vous avez bien
pas applaudissements c'est cher quand
accident je me suis pété la cheville
trouve on a une chance de dengue en
y est j'adore cette ambiance de mort
suisse t il ya de la verdure partout
voit la première leçon du tedx ne jamais
même on est d'accord
ouais ouais je me suis pété la cheville
fascinant par applaudissements à ce qui
est des gens qui aiment les musées
ouais c'était la première vannes clichés
hein c'est fou ce truc il suffit de
est vraiment tout cas c'est à dire que
ça me fait très plaisir d'être avec vous
faire de jeu de mots ça devrait être
c'est cher laisser fait bon après voilà
ok on est cultivé ça fait plaisir
s'endormir dans un bus pour basculer
de la soirée je pense vous mais usa les
alors on allait en afrique moi je suis
interdit mais je suis très contente
le pied est sorti s'est retournée
dans l'univers de martine à la ferme as
ce soir je suis très contente de faire
huées moi allez on y va
c'est vrai que c'est bien de penser
violent donc je crois pas que c'est ce
allé au centre de vaccination fascinant
alors moi j'aime bien les expos après
d'être là c'est vrai après quand on m'a
ce tedx avec vous donc voilà là c'est le
écolo quand on voyage par exemple pas ce
tu te réveilles a plus rien autour de
convoqué pour le tedx me suis dit purée
c'est par j'adore me mettre le public
qu'on pourrait dire que c'est de la
le centre de vaccination je veux juste
toi tout est en terre battue j'ai des
mobilité douce
mais se sont trompés sur le candidat du
c'est vrai que je trouve qu après avoir
soir chez venu en train en même temps
tout de suite dans la poche c'est cool
pas falloir m'expliquer pourquoi on te
petits cochons ils font coucou avec la
moment phone le moement fun c'est moi
et quand les médecins ils ont vu ma
piétiné pendant plusieurs heures on est
queue
y'a pas de vol genève fribourg
alors je très important quand tu fais un
rpt et moi je suis personne n'a jamais
donne une heure de rendez vous si c'est
paris c'est le délire ainsi tu t'en dans
tous un peu pareil on se dit [ __ ] fait
jambe ils m'ont dit ah c'est pas sympa
monsieur schnyder peut-être vous
rien fait de ma vie bon après j'ai su
pour te faire attendre trois heures dans
grand voyage à l'étranger il faut
donc on n'hésite pas à se lâcher ok ça
le métro tu te réveilles à un port qui
chier moi aussi j'ai envie d'être en
pourriez penser pour l'année prochaine
ça l'était
que c'était pour tedx fribourg ça va
s'informer sur les expositions à visiter
fauteuil roulant
la salle d'attenté
te fait coucou avec la queue
on fait un truc
et c'est vrai c'est facile moi je ferais
honnêtement je crois pas qu'il ya des
la loggia wagon j'étais au loup wiam à
assez vrai nom
va aller
donc avant d'arriver à fribourg j'ai
au bout là d'accord wheadon jeu non mais
saisons c'est sympathique
la même chose de plus une fois que
c'est moins bucolique c'est l'un des
j'invite quelqu'un à la maison un jeu le
un mec en fauteuil roulant je dois lui
non mais c'est vrai que c'est bien
triple fracture de la malléole et
faire patienter dans une pièce pourri
demandé de m'asseoir sur ses genoux bon
colis
regardé actuellement vous avez la 37e
je sens que vous êtes déjà très très
d'être écolo et de voyager en train je
alors après moi je suis donc suisse eut
avec une fontaine à eau une pile de
fracture du tibia péroné même avec une
après celui qu'il avait pas vraiment de
chaud alors on a eu l'intervention de
trouve c'est hyper important après moi
marie claire et un petit morveux qui se
raclette sais pas
genou donc j'ai pas
édition du traditionnel
aussi italienne je m'appelle cinzia
roule par terre je serai là j'en
mais c'est comme ça le voyage tu as des
y'a un truc qui m'énerve un peu avec les
christophe moreau qui a frôlé la mort
c'est un prénom que les gens ont
exposition poussins
viendrai vous chercher quand le hub
bref donc le thème de ce tedx c'est le
trains c'est que systématiquement quand
mairie de saïx bras
excessivement du mal à prononcer un il
accidents des aléas des rencontres et
ensuite vous avez eu une intervention de
moi j'ai vu ça je t'aime génial le
tu prends le train dans son wagon il ya
c'est horrible j'ai vraiment
c'est ce qui fait que c'est magnifique
est assez atypique si bien que si tu
voyage alors c'est vrai que quand la
18 minutes en allemand honnêtement j'ai
peintre non
toujours un bébé qui chiale
après on écrit des histoires c'est
littéralement attendu trois heures et en
prononces us du premier coup limite ça
crise climatique et la crise écologique
vous avez une exposition sur le poussin
fait c'est horrible parce que plus tu
c'est vrai tout le temps c'est au jeu
marrant ou pas mais voilà libre à vous
jamais eu des premières parties aussi
attends - tu peux partir un tas attendu
me choque je te jure tu prononces du
de juger mais c'est ça le voyage c'est
mortelle
bon le voyage c'est devenu un concept un
prend le train toutes les semaines à
non mais ça m'a rassuré et je me suis
trop longtemps pour te barres et du coup
chaque fois il ya un bébé qui chialent
beau c'est des rencontres c'est des
premier coup mon prénom physiquement je
non mais je le sent un peu la queue vous
petit peu abstrait si on suit cette
tu attends et je sentais vraiment
mais il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose d
rires c'est c'est des gens qui te font
sens que ça me fait quelque chose
le tedx non mais si pour vous le poussin
amis on devrait faire bah on devrait les
logique là des prochaines le thème ce
presque envie de coucher avec toi
intérieurement j'étais en train de péter
pleurer c'est des gens qui te font vomir
qu'après un parti fort la personne avant
un câble est en train de disjoncteurs et
sera l'orgasme féminin
est assez énigmatique pour le consacrer
c'est magnifique le voyage c'est toi qui
donc non andré j'ai pas c'est sûr la
mettre tous ensemble tu vois on devrait
moi lac à parler en allemand gregor
à mon avis les tueurs en série certains
faire un wagon que pour les bébés qui
adler je sens que ça vous a un peu
une 37e édition
te lève à 6h du matin et hop la donne en
présentation
chiale ce serait superbe comme ça on
mais sinon le voyage j'aime bien j'aime
c'est juste des gens qui ont pas rester
ça va
achevé je vois vos visages est déjà à
par où tu t'appelais pas andré quand je
minutes on train les supprimer le voyage
aurait le wagon bar le wagon des bébés
trop longtemps dans une salle d'attenté
bien
franchement j'estime être un petit peu
enfin j'ai eu la chance de faire des
qui chialent le wagon des fils de [ __ ]
ses poussins et des poussins le voyage
mais c'est vrai je devenais folle je
moitié du public qui au bout de sa vie
sur l'a7 à parce que peut-être nous je
grands voyages avec mes parents je suis
plus énigmatique qu'une nuggets ça va
tablais alain vrai bon ça la même chose
devenais folle et j'attendais
non mais c'est sympa parce que moi je
allé dans des endroits de folie vraiment
crois pas non non
c'est toi qui me ment sur ton prénom le
oui à la langue de goethe ans est
j'attendais et je me suis dit au bout de
je suis allé en tanzanie en islande au
vais vous faire rire donc j'ai un petit
c'est vrai c'est serré et ça en plus moi
on sait pas non plus
trois heures à mais en fait le vaccin
peu l'impression d'être un clown aux
clairement l'estiment que j'ai de moi
le voyage c'est le voyage c'est génial
vous êtes encore en train de le chercher
même non mais parce que ce soir je sais
soins palliatifs
plaisante alain alain jeumont pardon
locle
sacchi et c'est horrible parce qu'on est
ce qui m'énerve le plus tôt dans le
c'est cool alors personnellement j'étais
très bien que si je suis avec vous c'est
les amis et vraiment je suis tellement
train c'est que tu vois quand tu dois te
là bas comme comme monsieur morange et
uniquement pour vous rassurer je le sais
déplacer que tu as un peu pressé les
heureuse de pouvoir énormément voyagé
venu à moi afin de me dire mais
complètement largué pendant que grégoire
c'est fabio à s'adonner à ok donc tu ne
enfants du coup tu peux pas les dépasser
grâce à mon métier et l'humour alors
mademoiselle en fait vos vaccins sont à
j'ai vécu ni relief expérience bah rien
pas si non parce que là vous allez
adler parlait un je parle pas du tout
vu que c'est un couloir et ils sont là
j'espère que ce soir j'aurais pu vous
respectes pas jusqu'à la fin voilà
entendre des gens fascinants qui ont
jour
ils font les premiers pas et moi
faire voyager avec mes blagues merci
vraiment on me chie dessus j'adore fabio
allemand alors je sais pas vous mais
vécu des choses inwi est pris à moi qui
que d'être au locle en fait mon âme elle
j'estimerais que ce serait ok si tu es
j'avais attendu trois heures les amis
j'ai compris aucune de ses blagues jeux
beaucoup c'est tout pour moi merci
ok c'est vrai que c'est encore plus
un peu stressé et a passé une bonne
fais des jeux de mots sur les
s'est fait la malle
mais c'était horrible parce que j'ai
aspirateurs
rien du tout le seul truc du speech de
moche car bref allez
grosse journée par balayer tong aloi
mais c'est super j'ai aussi voyager
l'impression d'être plein de bonne
pas ou quoi ce pas je sais que je suis
donc
volonté d'avoir voulu faire quelque
beaucoup grâce à l'humour je joue dans
voilà je
grégoire adler que j'ai compris c'est
chose de bien et que tout ça ça avec
plein de villes différentes tout le
donc oui j'ai aussi cette chance donc de
pas là pour quota féminin je suis là
mets c'est pas que j'aime pas les
lsd et gregor adler voilà
temps et ça c'est une chance de d'un par
servi à rien j'avais un petit peu
voyager par l'humour j'ai fait beaucoup
pour le quota banalité
enfants mais en même temps qu'est ce
l'impression d'être le créateur du
exemple pas ce soir je suis avec vous à
qu'ils apprennent à marcher devant nous
de beaucoup de voyages si l'on
papier cadeau transparent
vous monsieur vous appelez comment
fribourg c'est génial fribourg j'adore 1
et pourtant je sais pas vous mais j'ai
pour brouiller le font pas ensemble tu
qu'italienne j'ai beaucoup d'amis en
le papier cadeau transparent les amis on
deuxième rang la milieu à la voie là bas
italie et mes amis de l'enfance et
fait des cours d'allemand à l'école et
c'est pas convaincu c'est votre villa
vois tous les bébés devraient apprendre
n'en parle pas assez non
italiens ans quand ils ont su que je
c'est dur l'allemand voterai pas
à marcher ensemble terme team building
vraiment défendent et là
alors c'est très important que tu saches
faisais du mourant francophonie mon dire
c'est super tribaux je trouve ça des
là ce serait génial on devrait faire un
que moi je suis vraiment comme vous dans
c'est dieu même le français je le
franchement c'est abusé non c'est à dire
assez marrant parce qu'un italien tu
la vie de tous les jours je suis
fitness et pour les enfants qui
quelqu'un de timide je descende scène je
paysans
maîtrise malin et pourtant c'est ma
que oui tu en balle mais on voit à
apprennent à marcher
nous a jamais fait rire
drogba qui s'est quand même l'avantagé
langue maternelle je le parle tous les
suis comme toi linge et plus de charisme
à quoi on a bien des fitness pour les
travers c'est un oxymore en fait c'est
ouais après moi j'ai une grande
jours mais honnêtement je connais ma
sportifs qui prennent encore à parler il
quand et je ne vois t'as pas besoin de
personnalité donc quand ils m'ont dit ça
quoi le prochain step de l'anti cernes
syntaxe gmac st b 1
y en a qui croient que j'ai passé qui
prendre l'avion pour arriver dans une
tout de suite je me suis imposé et je
grille des strip club féministes
leur ai dit rien rien du tout
zone en voie de développement
du coup j'étais assez stressé pour faire
mais voilà après je trouve que quand tu
il suffit de faire un thé dicks à
des billets des cff abordable les cff
ce speech ans ça me j'étais pas très
voyages le plus important c'est vraiment
fribourg oh ça va je vous taquine non
la tolérance la bienveillance et le code
bien et on m'a dit non mais t'inquiète
moi je dis ça parce que je suis
du wifi
pas te mets pas la pression
genevoise et d'ailleurs on dit très
c'est vrai quand tu voyages il faut
souvent que les genevois c'est un petit
le but du tedx c'est juste de diffuser
s'adapter aux autres cultures par
peu les parisiens de la suisse et c'est
exemple si tu vas en ouganda évite de
vrai que quand je suis à paris je suis
prendre des bains avec de l'eau potable
pas du tout dépaysé un jeu sans vraiment
voilà petit petit conseil pour moi
qu'on est entre connard
prendre un bain avec de l'eau potable en
ouganda c'est un petit peu comme faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]